d'une église l'autre de saint bernard à
saint-ambroise cinq mois d'errance
résumer en un parcours mouvementé à
travers la capitale
tout commence le 18 mars 300 africains
réunis en coordination soutenues par
l'association droit au logement investi
série saint-ambroise dans le 11e
arrondissement
ce qu'ils réclament les papiers dont ils
ont été privés après l'application du
nouveau code de la nationalité
plus connu comme les lois pasqua quatre
jours plus tard à la demande des
autorités religieuses l'église et
évacués par les crs
juste à côté les sans papiers leur
famille se réfugie alors dans le gymnase
japy suivra au fil des expulsions
successives et des soutiens fluctuant
un voyage tortueux entre salle
paroissiale entre qu'au théâtre siège
syndicaux mairie occupée
le 28 juin les sans papiers occupent
saint-bernard l'évêché joue la carte de
l'apaisement des médiateurs
autoproclamée tente en vain d'ouvrir des
négociations avec le gouvernement le 5
juillet dix sans-papiers entame alors
une grève de la faim la france à rabat
le 12 août réveil brutal les grévistes
sont hospitalisés de force 12 heures
plus tard ils reviennent le dossier
devient politiquement explosif à gauche
les soutiens à pluie le ministre de
l'intérieur je braque fond je suis la
majorité se divise le président du
groupe udf à l'assemblée nationale
gilles de robien temps une médiation le
premier ministre consulte le conseil
d'état sur l'application de la loi
pasqua
je vous le dis et je souhaite que vous y
réfléchisse y est l'application la loi
républicaine c'est le meilleur garant de
la solidarité entre les français et de
la cohésion nationale
alain juppé une fois l'avis du conseil
d'état rendu annoncé dès hier soir
l'évacuation